c'est toujours en fait la boule au
ventre qui ne s'estompe pas parce que
c'est extrêmement violent c'est indigne
et on a du mal à imaginer qu'aujourd'hui
on va avoir ce type de message en 2021
j'ai choisi de le rendre public j'ai
choisi de porter plainte et j'ai choisi
vraiment de le dénoncer le plus fort
possible pour que nos concitoyens
sachent les attaques parfois qui peut
subir d'antisémitisme mais comme toute
forme de racisme est absolument
incompréhensible et qu'est-ce que ça
puisse encore aujourd'hui s'exprimer
aussi aussi clairement c'est c'est
effrayant et c'est ça qui fait que
effectivement ça ne passe pas en
revanche ce qui est absolument
formidable c'est l'unité républicaine
qui s'est immédiatement manifesté soit
hier dans l'hémicycle où depuis où je
reçois des messages soient d'élus soit
de citoyens qui m'exprime leur soutien